okay lift number two is the shoulder
press and here's where I deviate a
little bit from RI as I mentioned in the
last post uh he's going to go into
shenai when he does this lift so that
and he's going to wait the bar on his
midfoot the entire time okay so first we
have to uh learn a couple
things um we want how wide is our grip
okay so your grip is going to be uh as
you address the bar you'll come in make
sure you align your nose on the center
of the bar between those inner nerling
marks your spine too and you just walk
in and then here we want our forearms
straight up and down so if the forearms
are out and you get that kind of
diagonal it's not going to it's too far
out if they're angled in it's too far in
and so A good rule of thumb for your
forearms being vertical is going to be
there in alignment with your shoulders
right with your should shoulders they're
not out of your shoulders and they're
not in of your shoulders right with your
shoulders
okay uh so you grab first center
yourself on the bar get your grip even
with your shoulders or where you think
it that is and as you work your way in
make sure you stay centered so he'll
work his way in and then he has his
knees
bent and he's under the bar he's a
little more forward of the bar cuz we
don't want to use our shoulders to get
the weight off we're going to use our
whole
structure now he straightens his knees
and the bar is up okay you take one to
two steps off back from the rack here we
have a chin up bar so you're just trying
to step to clear it the goal here is not
to take a lot of steps because you
should be lifting heavy and we don't
want to walk around with some weight
like that so one to two steps should do
it if your setup requires three steps at
fine just don't start walking all over
the place okay as we see him his legs
are straight underneath his hips they're
not wider Ronan we show that and they're
not narrower okay so inches and TI and
his feet are going to be straight so
he's going to fix his middle toe
straight there we go okay and now we're
in our normal cou cultivation stance
okay and what he's going to do
demonstrated here with outweigh is he's
going to bring his pelvis forward
slightly so that his head goes slightly
back and the bar is going to go straight
up and he'll bring his body back okay
let me scoop back a
little and then he reverses that action
down goes the bar all the way down he's
got tight shoulders from shoulder
injuries he got as a little kid um you
what you want to do is try to have this
sit on your chest okay and then he
repeats and you would do your set of
five okay what's key here in your set of
five go back down is that you're not
bending your knees at the bottom and
using leg strength to get it up we're
not doing that okay he's just moving his
head out of the way so that the bar can
go straight up on the midfoot vector as
he goes back and down straight up on
that midfoot Vector back
up okay and back
down then he'll walk it in and he'll hit
the up the uprights he's touching the
uprights he'll Bend his knee and it'll
fall into the J Hooks never aim for the
J Hooks hit the uprights and then bend
your knees let it fall into the J Hooks
all right we'll put some weight on it
and we'll show you what that looks like
okay sir he lines himself centered on
the bar in the nerling he gets his hands
uh shoulder width apart he'll walk
himself in and under the bar he's going
to straighten his legs bring the bar off
take one to three steps back and then he
proceeds as previously
demonstrated once it's back down he
walks it in hits the upright bends his
knees drops it on the J Hooks